when you wish to speak please click on
the raised hand
icon found by clicking on participants
and clicking on the blue raised hand
icon
at the bottom right of your screen
your raised hand icon will only be
lowered when you have spoken
you will be invited to speak in the
order of which your hands are raised
please unmute your mic with phone
before i invite you to speak and mute it
again
when you have finished speaking
please note this meeting will be live
streamed to the council youtube channel
this afternoon
please be mindful therefore that members
of the public
following the meeting via the live
stream
will be able to see each of us
individually on the screens
please announce yourself by name when
speaking
and if you want to refer to anything in
the office
offices report you please
speak clearly stating the relevant page
number
and paragraph number
thank you um do
do we have any apologies for absence
no apologies okay thank you members
um are there any substitute members this
evening
this afternoon
no no substitutes thank you are there
any
non-members attending today
[Music]
no okay thank you um
the minutes of the meeting that were
held on the first of july
uh of the sub sub committee
and held on the 6th of july members are
we happy with those we read those
minutes
yes ok thank you
do we have any declarations of interest
no there's no declarations of interest
thank you
um okay well we have the adoption of the
new pavement
permit permit licensing policy
um i would ask steve greener uh if he
would
give a brief summary of this for us
good afternoon everyone thank you very
much for for your time
um this is the adoption of the new
pavements permits licensing policy
and it follows the introduction of
government legislation
under the business and planning act of
2020.
the act provides a streamlined route to
apply for temporary pavement licenses
to enable premises to take advantage of
outdoor trading
during the summer months these new
measures are only a temporary measure
and are time limited and they will end
on the 30th of september 2021.
the tempering measures are to replace
the existing
policy that we currently have in place
currently under the pavement permits
licensing policy
and it currently operates under the
highways act of 1980
and the current policy requires a 28-day
consultation
the new consultation period
under the new act will be a seven day
consultation period
from the day after which an application
is made and the council has seven
days from the first day after the
consultation period
to determine the application if the
application is not determined within
those time scales then the license is
deemed to be granted
in accordance with the legislation and
the act the government has capped the
application fee
to no more than a hundred pounds
and the council proposes that the
application fee is set
at 100 pounds to cover the cost of
resources including officer time
incurred on the license application
process this represents a reduction
compared to the current fee
set at 260 pounds and 90p
within the new pavement permission
licensing policy
is set out in appendix a i know there
are certainly
a couple of questions and some
clarifications around
that delegation of powers the assistant
director
of people and communities is the
responsible officer
for taking decisions on this matter she
has the power to delegate in writing to
the licensing officers
the necessary powers to carry out the
functions and duties
under the act there are risks
associated with these once a license
premises pavement license is granted or
deemed to be granted the application
will also benefit from deemed planning
commission
to use the land for anything done to the
license
while the license is valid
the expectation is that the licensing
authorities will grant
pavement licenses for 12 months or more
unless there is a good reason for
granting a licence
for a shorter period such as plans for
the future
changing the use of road usage road
space if a license is deemed granted
because the authority does not make a
decision on an application
before the end of the determination then
the license will be valid for a year
under enforcement if a condition
imposed on the license either by russia
district council or nationally
is breached russia district council will
be able to issue a notice requiring the
breach to be remedied
and can take action to cover any cost
ratchet district council may revoke a
licence in the following circumstances
for a breach of condition there is a
risk to public safety
and public health the use of the highway
is causing an unnecessary obstruction
reaching
a non-obstruction condition
the uses is causing social behavior or
public nuisance
or it comes to light that the applicant
is falsely or misrepresented
represented the statement in their
application or
the applicant does not comply with the
requirements
to the effects noticed and notifying the
public
of the relevant period
in relation to the
equalities impact assessment this has
been completed
and there has shown that those with
mobility issues and those with visually
impairments the increase in street
furniture will impact on the space
allocated for pedestrians on the highway
to minimize this risk the standard
conditions
and national conditions have been
introduced to allow at least a two meter
walk-in
area to allow members of the public to
safely pass one another
without breaching social distancing
rules
section 3.1 of the act including
mobility
sets out a range of recommends whips
which
would be required depending on the
particular pavement
issuers or users the national conditions
states that the site
may need a barrier to separate furniture
from the rest of the footpath
so that the visually impaired can
negative
can navigate around the furniture
such as color contrast or tap rail for
longer cane users the recommendation is
proposed that the committee resolves
that
the revised fee for the pavement license
is set at 100 pounds
and that the pavement permits licensing
policy july 2020 to september
2021 is approved
and that's the end of the report
thank you members ah we have a
a question from councillor mike lucas
gill
go ahead please thank you chair um
steve do we have many premises that
currently have licenses
um for using the pavement and also what
about shops that have
barriers uh near their entrances
um i don't know why some of them are
there
right okay um at the present time we
have
only six that have got a pavement
license and that is renewed
each year i have already been contacted
by three of them to say that they're
going to be cancelling their policy
asking for a refund and we'll be
applying under the new
process obviously it's a lot cheaper for
them to do it under the new process for
12 months
in relation to barriers it all depends
on whether there's studs on the ground
and whether it's actually on their own
land or whether it's actually on
the highway this these applications only
apply to those that are on the public
highway
not those are actually on their own land
so it will be judged on an individual
basis
and it would have to be site specific
thank you steve could i just
clarify one point those who already have
a pavement license
uh why are they having to apply again it
is an annual
application or an annual renewal um and
they've sort of been holding off a
little bit because they knew that
obviously some guidance was coming out
obviously they would rather pay for
the the new sort of license under the
new costs
rather than the initial cost but like i
say i've had inquiries already from
those
that are keen to to apply as soon as the
new application form has been
uploaded onto the government site thank
you
thank you um councillor
mr hoy
thank you a bit slow coming off me too
um one question if i could answer that
first i've got something else afterwards
um you you referred to the market and i
noticed on um
appendix b um paragraph 26
and 27 refer to
the market um
so this is i mean 26 says the
seating shall not be placed outside when
a market stall is set out on the public
highway
and 27 says external seating
etc including planters to frontier
prices setting up the market
of the market the
seating and association paraphernalia
shall be immediately removed
is this the wording senior existing
policy
yes i actually took that off um some of
the
current pavement licenses that have gone
through planning
and actually that was the condition that
was attached by planning
so i've worked with planning to make
sure that we've tried to cover those as
much as we can
the clarity does that mean just outside
of the
premises who want the outside seating or
does it mean any premises
when a market is in the in the high
street or in the square
no it only applies to those that are
applying under this new pavement license
um like say some premises unfortunately
have got studs on the floor
that is under their own ground and they
would fall out of the remit of
this application process sorry i didn't
mean that i meant
if they are on the public highway or
public pavement would it
stop any premises from putting any
chairs or tables out on market day or
just those with a market still
on the pavement outside their premises
uh we can tailor it sorry it's site
specific um
but it i believe and i'll seek your
views
and it'll be best to actually have a
blanket on them all um
so there is consistency across the
approach but uh
anyone that is applying for
a pavement permission within either the
areas that have got the market
that on those days that none of them
will have
a tables and chairs outside on those
specific days
whereas for example if you are referring
to
would rayleigh have to stop having
tables and chairs out on a day that
right you're just holding its market
i think that what we're saying is that
only on the days that it's actually
holding the market in that area would
they then need to have to remove the
tables and chairs
and that is how the policy works now yes
okay i don't i don't think i can go
against policy as it is now it's been
set there quite a long time
um the other thing i i'd like to talk
about is the um
the fear of a hundred pounds um i know
it's reduced from 260 pounds 90 pence
to 100 pounds for these purposes the
hundred pounds is the maximum we can
charge
however i'm sure we all know the
problems that coffee shops and
restaurants have had over the past few
months
and how critical any additional income
is to them and how
any cost to them can be problematic even
though you may consider a hundred pounds
not a lot i would like to put forward a
motion where the um
the fee will be a zero we will not
charge a fee for this
as you said in a normal year it's six
we have we're foregoing income of 600
pounds we've
given other businesses um
i know it's government funded but we've
given them them funding i
think it would be appropriate in this
case to demonstrate our
determination to help the high street
that we reduce the fee to
zero and do not charge it so i just
propose that we i'm putting forward a
motion that the
in on page 6.13 uh paragraph 5.3 fees
that we would the the fee will be zero
i don't know if there's a seconder for
that do we have a second death please
yeah i'll second that thank you
um okay can we take a vote on that then
um going individually
yeah there's a point of order could we
debate it first
yeah sure
it's not normal to take a vote without a
discussion no okay
um first of all we have can i just
interrupt um
uh we we need to need to vote on the
amendment to the motion first
and then debate it and then vote at the
end please
okay
so i'll be happy to go with the
amendment if we could have a vote on
that please
i'm sorry i don't want to read my own
motion but i thought the rule was well
we debated
the uh amendment which i should mine is
the amendment
yeah yes before we vote on it
yes perhaps we're not allowed to debate
now you are
yes so first of all i have currently uh
councillor david merrick
um is is your um question still
relevant to the amendment councilman
merrick
no chairman it is it's it's not related
to the amendment
okay so we could move on to councilman
mrs mason please
thank you yes i'd like to speak to the
amendment
um i think um
much welcome the support to some of our
local businesses
which i trust will assist also local
employment
situation which we're all aware of is
tenuous at the moment
um most of the help so far that has been
provided to our local businesses and our
local population has been from
central government although distributed
via russia district council
means this this is a welcome opportunity
for russia district council to support
local businesses and to show
that the very small amount of small loss
of income
would actually be a large assistance to
the business
businesses that perhaps are going to
adjust may have to purchase new
furniture
and the a lot of cups of coffee are
going to have to be
sold to get that hundred pounds along
with the
original 260 90 so
i think the very least that rdc can do
to assist our local businesses
is to provide this facility free of
charge
for the short period of time that it
will be effective and i certainly
support the motion
thank you councilman
councillor mrs weston do you you have
something of the amendment
um i wasn't i will now um i'm
a bit concerned if we do do a zero um
uh a license for this because then it
could it could construe that we'll get
all
all
the um uh eating places
all come in and start putting out all
their chairs etcetera on
on this because we're not charging a fee
um i also believe that um
now that these places are being opened
they are charging more
for the services and for their food or
drinks what it is they're doing um so
i'm not too sure whether i could support
the hunt could support nil
rather than a hundred pound i still
believe we all we ought to
as a district be charging something
maybe not a hundred
but i'm not sure i could support it
entirely to be honest with you i just
get a feeling that we'll have all in
sundry out
thinking well we can all do it now it's
not going to charge us rdc
we'll still charge higher prices so i'm
a bit wary of it thank you
thank you council mr weston do we have
any other
ah okay so i've got counselor
mr hook way and then counsellor
mrs shaw
thank you chairman um yes i
i am i do support the amended motion
um and the reasons for uh supporting
this is that um
i understand uh what counselor
mrs mace mrs weston was saying in
relation to
um the possibility of a free-for-all
because
there's no charge but there's still a
process
that people do have to apply
and there is also the process whereby
there is some consultation period
and because of that that will probably
uh
um deter uh some people from
uh from going through the process just
because there is a process
um i think that um this is
meant to be an emergency uh measure to
try and stimulate some economic activity
and to try and boost some um
some footfalling in our in our high
streets and i think
uh if we if we are trying to help
in that respect then um the fact that
there's
not going to be a charge um
for for this service will definitely uh
be uh very much a useful useful measure
for
for the area which has had
the largest impact from this corona
virus lockdown which is obviously the
hospitality side
so um as i say i will be supporting the
amendment thank you
thank you council mr hawkway um
councillor mrs lauren shaw thank you
chair
um well i do agree with the emotion
that's been put forward not necessarily
not charging anything
i do think we need to look at our
businesses and get them up and running
but a lot of them have already had the
ten thousand pound grant so
they have had some help from not
necessarily
um rdc even though they gave them out it
was from the government
but i just put that out there they have
had this ten thousand pound grant i know
a lot of them having the square because
i've been out there talking to them
don't necessarily think we should charge
a hundred pound
perhaps a smaller amount thank you
thank you councilman mrs shaw um
councillor
mr hoy please
yes i am muted um yes uh thank you
chairman um
i think council hawkway put what i was
going to say quite well
however i just wanted to um
to to add sorry my brain is not working
very well today i'm afraid it's the
second meeting
um this is
only we're only talking about a few
businesses we've said six already
how many more are there that could
physically put chairs on the pavement
with the two meter rule in place anyway
um so it does restrict it quite a lot in
that case i'd also like to add that i've
not
i've eaten out a few places some of the
the places in um
in raleigh as well as in polbridge and
to my mind none of them put their prices
up in actual fact some have
given the um they've actually reduced
their prices with regards to the v80
so i don't think they're making more
money than they can and obviously within
inside they are reduced they they've
probably halved
i think most lines are looking at least
halved their capacity
so i don't i think it's very much needed
by this sector
and i think if you looked at the grimsey
report
which i've mentioned a few times on
other meetings
you'll find that the hospitality sector
before the virus was in desperate
straits anyway
and i think this this this will help
with a great deal it's
a hundred pounds is a is a lot to them
and i think the fact we're not charging
anything
shows the businesses in our district
that we will support them wherever we
can
i think i seem as important as the not
charging in itself
thank you councillor mr hoyer councillor
mrs weston
please thank you chairman um
i mean you know i agree quite a lot with
us meaning we've got the falls and
against on
on this ruling um one of the questions i
was going to ask
uh before um council ohio uh motioning
was um on the barrier side um you're
talking about this processes etc it's
kind of question i wanted to ask
if you're looking at this you're you're
saying we won't charge um
restaurants etc or or bars or whatever
to put
um seats etc out on the
out on the pavement my my concern again
is how you're going to
um deal with the barriers as uh
we were talking about sabrina was
talking about and when you say the
process
at the moment council hoy said you only
got about six or so
um come forward so far i
believe that we will probably have much
to probably double that um when they
know you haven't got to
to you're not charging the hundred pound
and also i agree like with councillor mr
shaw said you know they've had
government funding as well
um i'm just very very just very
conscious
really of um i think rdc do support
um you know our
restaurants etc in in and around
rochford
i'm just i'm just hearing caution i
suppose really on how
how we will deal with it if we don't go
down the route of possibly charging
something
i'm not against it but i'm just i'm just
weary of how it will how it will
proceed but i'd like to know about the
barriers because that would be one of
the that was one of the questions i
wanted to ask
uh mr greener on that if we if we do put
this through thanks chairman
okay can we um talk to the motion
that we're currently discussing and uh
if we're happy to go with the amendment
we can then
go back to uh steve greener to get some
clarification on the the barriers
okay thank you um is there anyone else
counsellor mrs mason please
no thank you madam chairman no you've
covered the point i was concerned that
the debate wasn't on the uh
amendment but was fearing off thank you
okay so we'll um just have a
a vote on this amendment then um
can we go through in in order to uh
to vote on this
so councillor carter if you could
indicate if you'd like a recorded vote
if you're voting for or against
or want to abstain please
yeah recorded vote for
counselor fd recorded vote for the
amendment
cancer mrs gooding
okay i'm for the amendment and i don't
need a recorded vote thank you
councillor hazelwood
sorry could you repeat that
against
was that against the recorded vote and
for the
amendment to the motion
um i would like a recorded vote and i am
for the amended motion
councillor hoy i'm for a recorded vote
and for the motion thank you
councillor lucas girl uh recorded vote
please
and for the motion
cancer mrs mason
thank you uh for the recorded vote
for the amended promotion thank you
counselor merrick
for the recording vote and for the
amendment
can submit shaw for a recorded vote and
for the motion thank you
councillor mr shaw for a recorded vote
for the motion
cancer mrs weston i don't need to record
your vote and against the emotion thank
you chairman
um
okay we have um
14 for the motion and two
against so the motion is carried
for the amendment thank you members
oh and the the recorded votes
sorry are they uh
sorry chairman um and they will be
recorded vote
okay they're all recorded thank you
okay so moving forward would we be able
to
ask steve greener please if you could
explain on the barriers
thank you very much um i draw your
attention to
appendix c of the reports which is on
page
6.30 um
these were the conditions are actually
added by the government not actually
added by ourselves
in relation to national standards
and it talks about there around the the
need for barriers to separate furniture
it's in the second bullet point down
says any need for a barrier to separate
furniture from the rest of the footway
so that the visibility impaired can
navigate around the furniture
such as color contrast and a attack rail
for
long cane users
in some cases it may be appropriate to
use
one or more rigid
removable objects to demark
the area to which the license applies
for example
wooden tubs of flowers however this will
need to be balanced to ensure that any
barriers will not
inhibit other street users such as the
mobility impaired
as such barriers may create a further
obstacle in the highway
so where they're actually talking about
barriers they're not just talking about
these sort of portable ones that are
attached
to sort of the the cafe type of barriers
that you'd quite see with the material
advertising
it could actually be different sort of
planters and different sort of measures
that could be used in place provided
that they could obviously be removed at
the end of the day
so it's quite open it's quite varied and
obviously
as part of the consultation period i'll
be working with planning
and also uh community safety and also
the parish councils to make sure that
we all work together to try and make
sure that they work
and there's nothing that stands out that
causes
problems to anyone else the very last
paragraph or bullet point on that
sort of page it says so that where
possible furniture is not reflective
of or reasonable substance
such that it cannot be easily be pushed
or blown over
by the wind and therefore causing
obstruction
so again they're talking very carefully
around what sort of measures that we
need to put in place
um so that again we make sure that no
one does get injured
if um these barriers have to be moved or
they are
more vulnerable does that help with the
question
thank you steve green greener um i'll
come back to councillor carol weston if
you could please
thank you chairman uh that's fine steve
can you just
um tell me are we going to make sure
that once these are in operation
we're going to have a general look
around all these uh sites just in case
they are
i know you're saying about us
counsellors and the parish councillors
keep an eye on
but aren't we going to have offices or
anybody going around to make sure that
they are in keeping with what
these bullet points say that's my own
question thank you
yes i can confirm that under um the
legislation it gives us enforcement
powers as i said before
um if they are breaching we're obviously
as part of their risk assessment and
part of their application we're going to
ask them if they're going to include
barriers what type of barriers they're
going to install um to make sure that
obviously
we're fully aware of the full detail
before the application is granted
and then it'll be down to ourselves um
to obviously then
look at if they are breaching any of
those conditions or any of those
requirements that we added on
then obviously we could look at either
issue in a notice
or a worst case scenario is actually
revocation of the license
so yes we will be looking at that
thank you steve marina um can i
this is councilman mason please
mrs councillor mason please
counselor mrs mason even
that's better thank you um could the
officer confirm
that this um policy
would also stand up to any change of use
should closure of the roads be
implemented as being
um permitted and
allowed under the new regulations
if that was to be adopted in rockford
would the policy that we're adopting now
still cover that process
in other words
i think the question is for example if
we suddenly closed off rochas square to
make it all pedestrianized would that
allow
or see tables and chairs to be put out
like what we would find in sort of a lot
of european towns
or the same with raley high street if we
closed off raleigh high street and
allowed tables and chairs to go out
yes that would under the highways
actually still obviously work with
highways but yes this policy does
actually cover all those sort of
circumstances
and again i'll be working with all our
partners around
highways police and
environmental health and planning to
make sure that uh
we look at all um different sort of
obstacles
um to then obviously try and work with
the businesses so yes
thank you thank you members
do we have any more questions or any
other
concerns
of counsellor mr hookway
uh thank you chairman uh yes i would
like to ask stephen greener
um a question in relation to um
what specifically uh
the council is going to do to actively
promote
this change in policy um so that
uh the businesses that have the
opportunity to make best use of this are
going to have
the also have the opportunity to be
aware
and have the process of applying for for
this
this opportunity to increase their trade
i can say that already i've been working
with the economic development team and
also the we're back team
around obviously they knew that this
pavement
sort of licensed and the business and
planning act was coming
through so obviously i've been liaising
with those um we've had a number of
inquiries already that i've actually
saved up their email addresses
and i've already sort of emailed them to
say look we've got the the application
process coming
and that i'll be in contact with them
again once the actual um
the policy has then gone through and all
the agreements have been made
so we'll make sure that it does go
through our social media channels within
rocha district council
and also as well i'm a member of the um
rayleigh pub watch so obviously i can
then promote that to all the pubs within
um rayleigh and also i can then contact
all the licensed premises
and um in richard and also the cafes as
well to say
look this is now available to you
okay thank you thank you
mr greener um counselor mr merrick
please
thank you chairman um i've got a few
admittedly minor points uh
which i think will require some
amendment
if i may go through them
the first is on page 6.3
and there no i beg upon i've dealt with
that one
uh 6.12
paragraph 3.5
two points on on this
on the last sentence and easily and
stored away of an
evening i'm not quite sure that that
makes sense
okay are there some words missing there
um no he's just easily stored away of an
evening
he should be the the correct comment so
uh
i'll take out the um the and and the
comma
um so that it can be easily stored away
sorry
yeah i i thought it meant at the end of
an evening or something like that
okay um also in that same paragraph
uh i'm not sure the relevance of the
words in principle
because it seems to me this gives rise
to the possibility of an
argument as to whether
it applies or not
i mean either it is is not a permanent
fix
structure or it is i'm not sure where
the in principle comes in
yeah i'm happy to also remove that bit
which says um
so that revised sort of paragraph is
this
furniture is required to be removable
and then this means is not a permanent
fixed structure
and it is able to be moved easily
can be removed easily and stored away
of an evening okay are you is that okay
yeah i'd be happy with that yeah
then i moved to page 6.16.
um paragraph
6.7 and right at the end
it refers to levels of pedestrian or
cycle
movements um
would this not be on areas where cycle
movements are illegal anyway
i'm just finding the page so
it's six point one uh six point sixteen
did you say
six point sixteen yeah this is the end
of paragraph
six point seven
other uses users of the space for
example
if there are high levels of pedestrian
or cycle movements
thank you sonia
yes i think this was um part of the
actual recommendations
that was in the draft policy
it was put in there just in case that
some people wanted
uh had cycle lanes within the areas
and that obviously that the tables and
chairs could effectively be used in
those cycle lanes
right yeah that was the principle behind
it
yeah i'm obliged on that thank you um
i now go to page
6.20
very minor very minor point this 8
8.2 i'm sorry
yeah 8.2
i think the word in the first sentence
licenses
should be licensed yes
i will make sure that's amended if i may
go back to 6.17
paragraph 6.14
and i apologize for being a bit pic
picky
licensing should be spelt with an s
i should know that thank you very much
yes
easily john easy
um so i may now move to page 6.25
[Applause]
paragraph 7.
movement
the second line doesn't seem to me to
follow in
automatically from the first line and i
wonder if some
one or more words are missing okay let's
read that
you say against yeah yeah yeah
i think this is this is something as as
minor as that
and i think the same point applies
on page 6.26
at paragraph 17.
okay so the license holders is not to
make
or cause or make against
or cause to be made any claim for
just i'll have a look at that so yeah
it's just
like so he's just rewording that
number it's not
i'm not changing the sense or anything
it's just it just seems to have a word
missing yep license holder is not to
make or cause time saves
any claim against roger district council
in the event
6.26
17 right at the bottom
where the consumption of alcohol is to
take place the only
plastic or tough glass
to be used yeah
so it should read where the consumption
of alcohol is to take
place the only use of plastic or
toughened glasses
um is to be permitted or something to be
committed
okay yep yep that that that was all
thank you very much thank you thank you
jim
okay um counselor mr hoy please
sorry i was so interested in them
councillor eric some
proofreading that i've actually
forgotten what was going to solve
so i'll i'll leave oh don't worry about
me thank you
thank you may i add gemini i haven't
proved read it
i can't guarantee that is exclusive
it was still very impressive though
thank you
councilman mrs carol wisconn plays
weston hello carol wesken
sorry all right just do it now i'm just
going back again
um the council mr hoises there was about
six that he knew of who was in in this
um for not being charged
does mr green you know he was talking
about he's now being put putting out to
be put out to the um
to the establishments has any idea
of how many he will be he will be
looking at
that will be using this service without
having to pay the
the fee please uh chair i don't think
he's got any ideas at all thank you
thank you
yep i can um say so far i have got
eight that are currently waiting for the
permission to apply
um for these licenses
i don't know their locations i know of
two
um that have obviously contacted me that
are individual cafes
that are very interested in it i have
been contacted by solicitors for the
other ones so i i can't actually confirm
their locations
at this time
thank you
councillor mrs mason do you have a
question
thank you madam chairman um firstly i'd
i'd like to
endorse what councilor hoye said i'd
like to applaud councillor merrick for
his attention to detail
it's impressive but whilst he was
bringing these points to mind i noticed
another one where we have a slight uh
contradiction should we say and it's
only due to councillor
merrick's attention to detail that i've
picked it out
on page 620
8.2 richard district council will grant
us
a license and we made that singular and
calcium eric's a
request for 12 months unless there are
good reasons however
this policy goes until the 30th of
september
so i think we need to um
alter that 12th month until the 30th of
september
2021 because otherwise someone applying
in
august will lose three weeks next year
we don't want to have them to have to
reapply
it would be a waste of our time and a
waste of their time
so for that very short period it needs
to be
obviously if it's a shorter period then
that's fine
but it's it's a bit of a nonsense
and i don't know if it's anywhere else
they're the date of
august or 12 months but if so we need to
be
consistent i mean if you look at page
2.6.23
it says which is scheduled to expire on
the 30th of september
21 so we just need to be slightly
consistent
so um thanks to council merrick's
attention to detail i've
also picked that one up if we could
alter that please thank you
mr greenery you happy to agree that
uh so just for clarity that if someone
was to apply
that they will be issued a license until
the 30th of september 2021 is that
correct
yes yes because otherwise otherwise if
you um
grant a license say on the 10th of
august
and it's for 12 months they're going to
have to reapply
for 20 days which is not the intention
of this
i'm sure so i think it's because i think
you've got the 30th of september further
down but you haven't got it in that
particular
sentence and it's quite hard when you're
drafting this amount of detail i'm sure
so i'm not trying to be critical i just
want to be constructive
thank you now if with permission i will
then change
um 8.2 to say roger district council
will grant a license
until the 30th of september 2021
unless there are good reasons for
granting a licence for a shorter period
is that sufficient thank you yes that's
perfect
okay so we've debated this uh
amendment um
are we um happy to go with the
recommendation
and uh and agree that
recommendation members
do we need to vote on the the amendment
to the recommendation
which is recommended as amended
chairman we we've got two
recommendations haven't we at paragraph
9.1 of the report with paragraph
with with recommendation one being
amended
to uh to zero pounds um
our members happy to uh vote on those
two recommendations
together um
perhaps they could indicate by by race
you know if they're not are we happy to
all you're happy okay
okay so we'll take a vote on both of
those
recommendations please with the
amendment
sorry chairman may i just say the
question because i
uh voted against the hundred pound i
can't vote for both together can i
sorry that's just a question okay
um cancer mrs weston you could uh you
could have your vote um
uh you know recorded as being against
that if you wanted to
in the minutes it's a recorded vote
anyway
okay
so members we're voting for um
recommendations one and two
recommendation one as as amended
um can i please um ask you if you'd like
a recorded vote
or if you want to vote for gangster
abstain
so councillor carter
yep i'm voting for both recommendations
recommendations
counsellor mrs gooding recorded vote and
voting for both recommendations thank
you
cancer hazelwood thank
i sorry i didn't get that counselor
hazelwood
um can you um can you please indicate
with your raised hand icon um if you
want a recorded vote
okay and are you voting for
or against against okay
councillor hookway
for a recorded vote and for the motions
thank you councillor hoy
uh four recorded vote and for the
motions thank you
thank you council lucas gill for
a recorded vote and for both motions
cancer mrs mason
um for a recorded vote and for both
emotions thank you
councillor merrick
or a recorded vote and for both
emotions counselor mrs shaw
for a recorded vote and for both
recommendations
as i've been as amended please
absolutely sure for a recorded vote
for both motions
counselor mrs weston uh for recovery
vote
uh against you know recommendation one
and uh four for recommendation uh be
approved for
number two thank you chairman
okay
so there will be a recorded vote um
there are
11 voting uh four
recommendation one and two against
and there are 11 voting for
recommendation
two and one against
thank you members we have no other
business this afternoon
and i think that concludes the meeting
thank you all for your time
thank you chad thank you